I'm here to talk to you about an issue
that is close to my heart
Custer fists cluster fest is a comedy
festival that acts like a music festival
is a festival that's all about comedy
music and comedy this is for one thing
most people smell better this festival
is no joke instead it as many many jokes
told over three days and multiple stages
closer fest is your chance to make your
voice heard
specifically the sound of your voice
haha whether you've got a great ha ha or
a weird ha ha hey everybody's welcome to
cluster fast laughter is good for your
heart and great for your skin it's gonna
be a whole weekend of the best moments
of your life sorry if you have children
or you've gotten married or whatever
that's about to move down on your list
someday you gonna tell your grandkids
about this amazing lineup if you even
want kids there's no pressure whatever
you want to do John mulaney's Sinbad
Whitney comes in a whole bunch of the
names I don't have time to read right
now take Notaro Amanda Thiele Colin Jost
Amy Poehler chelsea peretti
Nick Thune wow that's a big guy who's it
from the Dan band and Big Freedia I
can't wait to wear the roots it's the
band Japanese breakfast on one stage and
Issa Rae podcasts like disk Riesling and
comedy bang bang you can see Courtney
Barnett you could see my favorite murder
we may find out what Sinbad's favorite
murders are your only chance is one
weekend this June in San Francisco yup
the place from the full house Centro and
guess what weed is legal there and what
goes better with weed than comedy music
drag and more comedy Trixie Mattel
peaches Christ and Katya doing a live
reading of Romy and Michele's high
school reunion they've got that there's
gonna be drag queens gross battles
indoor bathrooms yes air conditioned
venues you bet your ass place to sit
down
absolutely what you get to visit the
office from the office you know who
didn't get to do that Judy Garland she's
dead
we've all done things that we regret in
life missing cluster fest does not have
to be one of them truly I'm Nicole Byer
I'm comedy and musics Craig Robinson I'm
guy Brown if it's the Stefon Ilana
Glazer Ben de Matteo
I'm patton oswalt Nick Thune Clinton
Brunson I'm comedy's Jeff Ross and I'm
going to cluster past Sochi I hope to
see you there
for me I'm going to cluster fast
[Music]